>>> DANGEROUS AND RECKLESS,
THAT'S HOW THE CIA DIRECTOR
DESCRIBED RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN WHEN HE IS
CORNERED, THIS, AS THE RUSSIAN
LEADER WARNED THAT THEY MIGHT
FIRE NUCLEAR WEAPONS AT THE
WEST.
WHILE THOUSANDS OF HIS PEOPLE
FLEE RUSSIA'S MILITARY DRAFT AND
AS UKRAINE MAKES GAINS IN THE
EAST.
>> HE'S GOT TO BE CONCERNED NOT
JUST WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE, WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT HOME AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING INTERNATIONALLY.
HE STOOD NEXT TO XI JINPING
RIGHT BEFORE THE WAR STARTED AND
THEY PROCLAIMED A FRIENDSHIP
WITH LIMITS.
TURNS OUT CHINESE HAS LIMITS TO.
THEY HAVEN'T PROVIDE THE KIND OF
MILITARY SUPPORT THAT PUTIN HAS
BEEN LOOKING FOR AS WELL SO HE'S
GOT TO BE TROUBLED BY WHAT HE
SEES.
HE'S ALSO STUBBORNLY CONFIDENT
IN HIS OWN JUDGMENTS.
HE BELIEVES HE'S TOUGHER THAN
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> YOU MAKE IT SOUND LIKE HE'S
EVEN MORE DANGEROUS.
>> PUTIN CORNERED, PUTIN WITH
HIS BACK AGAINST OF WALL CAN BE
RECKLESS.
>> JOINING ME FORMER CIA TERROR
OFFICIAL PHIL MUDD.
AND KNOWS WHEN IT COMES TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN, CORNERED,
RECKLESS, DEFENSIVE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THAT MEANS, PHIL?
>> I'M TAKING THIS, FIRST, JOHN,
FROM LOOKING FERNLT THE CIA
DIRECTOR DIRECTOR BURNS WHO I
KNOW, HE'S A SUBDUED UNDERSTATED
INDIVIDUAL.
HE'S BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME
HE KNOWS THE RUSSIANS.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT SAYING,
YOU GOT TO TAKE IT AT FACE
VALUE.
IF YOU'RE SITTING IN THE
SITUATION ROOM IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, YOU GOT TO MAKE SURE YOU
DON'T TRANSITION FROM WHAT YOU
THINK TO WHAT YOU KNOW.
YOU THINK BASED ON WASHINGTON
INTERPRETATION THAT IT WOULD BE
HIGHLY UNLIKELY FOR THE
RUSSIANS, FOR EXAMPLE, TO USE
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE DO NOT KNOW THAT.
THAT WOULD SEEM TO BE A RASH
MARE BY PUTIN BUT BASED ON WHAT
DIRECTOR BURNS IS SAYING, YOU
GOT TO LOOK AT THE WHITE HOUSE
AND SAY WE DON'T THINK THEY'D
USE TACTICAL NUKES.
BUT WITH THE ASSESSMENT OF PUTIN
SAYING HE'S DANGEROUS AND
CORNERED, WE CANNOT ASSUME THAT.
WE DO NOT KNOW THAT AND WE'VE
GOT TO AT LEAST PLAN FOR THAT
EVENTUALITY, IT IS REALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE, JOHN.
>> HOW GOOD IS U.S. INTELLIGENCE
NOW ON VLADIMIR PUTIN?
PARTICULARLY HUMAN INTELLIGENCE
ABOUT WHAT HE DOES, WHAT HE
THINKS, HOW HE FEELS RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER YOU MIGHT NOT EXPECT.
I WOULD SAY DON'T COUNT ON IT.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS GOING
ON HERE.
THERE'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
ASSESSING WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
RUSSIA IN THE BATTLEFIELD.
I WOULD JUDGE THAT THE
AMERICAN -- THAT THE CIA AND
DEFENSE INTELLIGENCE AT THE
PENTAGON ARE VERY GOOD ON THIS.
AND PROBABLY EXCELLENT.
THERE'S A LONG WAY BETWEEN THAT
AND GOING TO MOSCOW WHERE I'M
GOING TO JUDGE WE HAVE LIMITED
ACCESS TO PUTIN'S INNER CIRCLE.
AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE MIND OF A MAN WHO USED
TO BE A SPY.
EVEN IF YOU HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INNER CIRCLE, JOHN, YOU CAN'T
ASSUME THAT EVEN PUTIN IS
TELLING THE INNER CIRCLE WHAT HE
THINKS OR WHAT HE KNOWS HE'S
GOING TO DO NEXT WEEK.
HOW THE HECK DO WE KNOW.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE JUDGMENTS
ABOUT HOW AGGRESSIVE HE MIGHT
BE.
HOW DANGEROUS HE MIGHT BE BUT
THOSE ARE SQUISHY JUDGMENTS IN
MY EXPERIENCE, JOHN.
>> PHIL, WE'VE GOT 30 SECONDS WE
KNOW THERE ARE DIPLOMATIC BACK
CHANNELS THAT STATE OFFICIALS
SPEAK TO OFFICIALS OVERSEAS.
WHAT ABOUT INTELLIGENCE BACK
CHANNELS?
>> THERE WOULD BE, BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO ASSUME THAT THOSE BACK
CHANNELS HAVE ANY WAY TO
INFLUENCE VLADIMIR PUTIN.
PEOPLE ARE TALKING TO MOSCOW AND
ELSEWHERE, DON'T COUNT ON IT,
PUTIN'S HIS OWN MAN, JOHN.
>> PHIL MUDD, SOBERING TO SAY
THE LEAST.
THANK YOU.
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
EXPECTED TO SIGN INTO LAW TODAY
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WOULD
ILLEGALLY ANNEX FOUR REGIONS OF
UKRAINE.
THIS HAS RUSSIA CLAIMED 200,000
PEOPLE HAVE JOINED THE MILITARY
AS PART OF THEIR CONSCRIPTION,
THEIR NEW MOBILIZATION.
AND VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY SIGNED A
DECREE RULING OUT THE IDEA OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH PUTIN CALLING
IT AN IMPOSSIBILITY.
JOINING ME NOW IS JOURNALIST
JULIA.
THANK YOU AND CONGRESS ON THE
BOOK.
>> THANK YOU.
UKRAINE IS VERY IMPORTANT THESE
DAYS.
>> OBVIOUSLY.
AND FOR YOU, PARTICULARLY TO SEE
WHAT RUSSIA HAS DONE TO THESE
TERRITORIES IN THE EAST.
ONE OF THEM BEING THE CKHERSON
REGION WHERE YOU ARE FROM.
I WONDER YOUR REACTION TO THE
LAW THAT PUTIN IS SIGNING TODAY
AND WHAT YOUR HEARING FROM THE
LOVED ONES STILL THERE?
>> WELL, POPPY, IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO SEE HOW RUSSIA
TRIES TO INVADE ACTUALLY MY
MEMORIES, MY CHILDHOOD, THE
PLACES WHERE I WAS BORN AND
BROUGHT UP.
BUT, IN FACT, WE SEE THAT NO ONE
IN THE WORLD EXCEPT NORTH KOREA
RECOGNIZES THIS ANNEXATION.
AND OF COURSE UKRAINIAN ARMY AND
PRESIDENT DO NOT.
TODAY WE'VE HEARD THAT FIVE
SUPPLEMENTS IN THE KHERSON
REGION WERE LIBERATED BY
UKRAINIAN ARMY AND WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THEY WILL MOVE FORWARD.
WE ALSO HAVE HEARD THAT THE KEHM
LYNN SAID THAT THEY DO NOT KNOW
THE EXACT BORDERS OF THE
TERRITORIES THAT THEY WANT TO
ENACT WHICH MEANS THEY'RE
STRATEGY IS JUST TRYING TO PUSH
FAKE DEMOCRACY, NOT TO STOP.
BUT RIGHT NOW WHAT I'M
EXPLAINING IN THE FIGHT OF OUR
LIVES, WHAT WE SEE IS WHO IP
VADED OUR COUNTRY AND KILLED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND
HE TOOK OUR LAND AND NOW WE SEE
THAT HE TRIES TO PUSH PERHAPS
SOME MOMENTS ABOUT NEGOTIATIONS.
WHEN ACTUALLY HIS ARMY IS BEING
DEFEATED BY THE UKRAINIAN ARMY
RIGHT NOW.
>> OUR VIEWERS HEARD WHAT I JUST
READ LEADING INTO IT, WHICH IS
WHAT PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS
SAYING NOW, WHICH IS NO WAY
WOULD WE NEGOTIATE WITH RUSSIA
AFTER THEY'VE DONE ALL OF THIS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, PUTIN CON
SCRIPTING 200,000 SOLDIERS.
WE SAW THE VIDEO OF THEM DOING
EVERYTHING THEY COULD, MANY
PEOPLE TO AVOID JOINING THE
RUSSIAN ARMED FORCES.
HOW LONG COULD PUTIN SUSTAIN
THERE AND IF THERE IS NO
NEGOTIATION ON THE TABLE, THEN
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS GOING?
>> POPPY, WHAT WE ACTUALLY SEE
RIGHT NOW IN THE MOMENT ONLINE,
WE SEE THAT ALL OF OUR UKRAINE
AND OUR WESTERN ALLIES ACHIEVED
RESULTS ALREADY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SHOWN GREAT
COUNTER OFFENSIVES WITH
REGAINING KHARKIV AND
ZAPORIZHZHIA AND KHERSON.
OUR HARMY IS BETTER PREPARED
TH
THANKS TO OUR INTERNATIONAL
ALLIES.
WE JUST NEED TO PUSH MORE TO GET
FREE FROM THE ARMY.
LET ME SAY.
IF PUTIN WERE SERIOUS ABOUT
FINISHING THIS CONFLICT, THERE
IS NOTHING THAT DOES NOT ALLOW
HIM TO TAKE HIS ARMY, TO
WITHDRAW ARMY OUT OF THE
TERRITORY OF UKRAINE.
UKRAINE WANTS PEACE.
BUT WE CANNOT ALLOW SOMEONE TO
INVADE OUR COUNTRY, KILL TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, TO SEE ALL
OF THIS ENORMOUS DESTRUCTION
WORTH BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND THEN JUST TO FORGET
AND FORGIVE.
ESPECIALLY AT THE MOMENT WHEN WE
SEE THAT WE CAN REGAIN OUR
PEOPLE AND OUR TERRITORIES BACK.
I KNOW FROM OCCUPIED
TERRITORIES, FROM THE PEOPLE WHO
I KNOW VERY CLOSELY THAT THEY
ARE STILL WAITING AND THEY
CELEBRATE THE ACHIEVEMENTS THE
UKRAINE ARMY.
THAT IS WHY UKRAINE ASKED TO
STAND WITH US TO THE VERY END.
WE CAN ACTUALLY FINISH THIS EVIL
BY TAKING THE RUSSIAN ARMY OUT
OF UKRAINE.
AND THEN WE WILL NEED TO TAKE
RUSSIA -- TO HOLD RUSSIA
ACCOUNTABLE.